esta es nuestra área de recepción
cohen es uno de los propietarios de
estos almacenes donde venden productos
farmacéuticos como la pastilla del día
después la marca plan b está aquí tienen
hasta cinco marcas distintas y tenemos
más de la marca my shoes aquí porque
aquí se enteraron de que la corte
suprema había limitado el derecho al
aborto porque las ventas se dispararon
en su página web
nos levantamos y vimos cientos de
pedidos de pastillas de emergencia y fue
cuando dijimos algo no está bien
consultamos google y vimos la decisión
del supremo
desde entonces no hay descanso miles de
estadounidenses están comprando esta
píldora la gente está comprando está
almacenando porque no saben qué va a
pasar hoy ha sido el aborto pero mañana
podría ser las pastillas de emergencia
lo que prohíben la gente quiere estar
preparada y si antes se compraba una
media de dos pastillas por cliente
ahora están acumulando y la media por
pedido es de cinco o seis cajas este es
nuestro chico de fe de escaneando los
pedidos cada día salen de este local
1200 cajas 5 veces más que antes de
conocerse el fallo del supremo la
mayoría con destino a los estados más
conservadores donde prohíben el aborto
ante el aumento de la demanda algunas
farmacias en el país como la que ven
detrás de mí han limitado el acceso a
esta pastilla a un máximo de tres por
cliente para evitar la escasez de
existencias por eso muchos
establecimientos la píldora se guarda
bajo llave como si fuese oro en otros ya
ni siquiera quedan y en la farmacia de
marta las cajas que hay también están
así de protegidas
es increíble que tengamos que vivir esto
pero es un reflejo del miedo que hay
entre las mujeres en esta sociedad
porque no sabemos qué va a pasar en un
futuro y por eso cohen ya se prepara
este mes ha doblado su pedido a los
fabricantes de píldoras para asegurar el
stock del producto más buscado por estos
días en eeuu